it's almost like you know a Mother's Day
present from me to my mom in a lot of
ways you know I even told her about the
song and I'm Union if the cover art is a
picture of my mom and high school life I
write it into high school and which is
right I think the picture was sort of
right before she found out that I was
coming along so it's pretty special to
me in a lot of ways like that but yeah
you know I hope that people connect to
it that way and I hope that MA you know
as much as any they're holding moms
appreciate it because you know mama was
pretty special to me growing up and then
and then I know how special and how
important faith is to my girls in their
life okay Keith
now sung it for the Bruce cat in the cup
level trees I thought of home after I
waited here this is coming up for
Mother's Day mom I want you to hear it
he loved it she said boohoo emojis to me
my mom's emojis I just
I was missing you and
so I wanted to thank you hear it but I
didn't want to play it for on the phone
I wanted to sing it to it so listen to
it for about 30 minutes and I tried to
sit down and sing the song to her and I
got to the hook and I just fell apart I
couldn't sing the hook I'd cry every
time I got to it
[Music]